Speaker 1: OK, let's now move on to the next
one. Rand Paul. Rand Paul did one of these
town hall virtual town halls recently
and a Kentuckian named Alexis Toon,
she says she was contacted to participate in the
town hall. It's there's conflicting reports about
whether anybody could just call in or whether she
was called to participate or whether she asked to
be called. But she told Rand Paul to get left
during the town hall. All right. Let's take a
look at the clip. And, you know, to some degree, I
want to mention that there is language that may be
disturbing to some individuals and just
letting everybody know about that. OK,
here, let's listen to Rand Paul for that.
Speaker 3: We'll go ahead to our next question
now. Mrs. Alexis Tune, you are live with the
senator. You can go ahead and ask your question.
Hey, Senator, I am a proud Kentucky citizen,
and I just wanted to tell you to get
home and. All right, we'll go ahead.
Speaker 1: So a few a few thoughts on this.
There is not even a debate here. This is
completely fine now, much like with the
Tucker Carlson confrontation where Dinesh
D'Souza said the man who confronted Tucker
Carlson should be arrested, which is just sort
of like a complete and total joke with this one.
There is not even a debate as to whether this
is OK. Oh, foul language. Oh, give me a break.
I have no problem with this whatsoever. Could
you make the case that with the opportunity
that she was given Alexis to and could have
made a substantive confrontation of Rand Paul?
Sure, you could say that. I don't know that
it would have gotten this level of attention.
And you can just tell Rand Paul has very much
practiced that complete and total non reaction,
his face not even moving when when the bomb
drops. But I have to tell you, other than if you
think about the Senate, maybe Ted Cruz deserves
this more. Maybe Josh Holly deserves this more.
It's hard to think of someone more deserving
than to be confronted for the moron that he is
than Rand Paul. That's the Senate. Now, if you
want to look at the House of Representatives,
there's a very long list of people who deserve to
be confronted. Marjorie Taylor Green, Matt Gaits,
Lauren Bobert, Madison Cawthorn, Kevin McCarthy,
Jim Jordan. You know, it's a very, very long
list. And as childish as this is, like in all
seriousness, elected officials should be less
isolated from just the thoughts of random people.
I am never advocating for physical violence. I'm
not saying throw eggs or milkshakes. I'm not
saying anything, anything like that at all.
I'm talking about just words and really having
to face the reality that what they are doing
is not only disgusting to millions of Americans,
but it's also really bad for the lives of millions
of Americans. The policies that they support are
terrible for millions and millions of Americans.
That's just the reality that they should have
to face. And, you know, whether the extraneous
whether the out of school, the after school
language, so to speak, has to be a part of it. No,
I am not saying that I don't really care about
that. But being in less highly curated moments
where this can actually happen, I think is a good
thing for our elected officials. And some of you
may say, well, Joe Biden never does that. Joe
Biden has had to deal with Peter Doocy, one of the
Steve No. Pedia Peters, the kid, an extremely
hostile reporter, and he regularly goes to him.
Now, do I want Joe Biden talking more to voters
who disagree with him? Yeah, I would like that.
I think that that's just a great thing. And I
try to take calls when we do live calls from
people who disagree with me. And one of the
things that I think is important to remember
my view is even the people who call me in complete
bad faith and want to sandbag me and they swear
and they insult or whatever, sometimes there
is a kernel of truth to the inconsistency that
maybe they're pointing out in a position that
I've taken or whatever I find significant value
of that. And if our elected officials were more
regularly exposed to that, I think it would be
a very good thing. Make sure you're following
me on Instagram at David Pakman. I posted my
second eggplant over the weekend. The picture went
insta viral, more because of what was on my head.
Then the eggplant itself. Take a look
at it. Let me know what you think.